Many people tend to take jobs for the wrong reasons...
...or because the jobs are what the family deems right.
They have been programmed to follow rules, punch the proverbial time clock...
...and do what is right, but not for themselves.
Chasing tradition or other people's ideas about what is right for you is just wrong,...
...even if it happens to be your well-meaning teachers or parents.
When we turn 80, what we didn't have the guts to do...
...will be far more of a problem than those things we did try that didn't work.
Chasing security or someone else's dreams, isn't only insidious,...
...it's guaranteed to lead to a schizophrenic existence.
A recent study revealed that the number one wish of most working people was to retire.
How pitiful!
Passion is the investment of those chasing inner dreams,...
...and one of the payoffs is living a long, happy life.
Plato opened up the Academy in Athens when he was 40...
...at a time when the life expectancy was 36.
He ran this first university, training such stalwarts as Aristotle, until he was 80.
Pursuing positive dreams arms one with high energy and leads to a long, fulfilling life.
Do such people get paid?
Absolutely!
Those who execute positive dreams will see money by the truckload.
If you're passionate, use your talents,...
...and make sure someone will pay you for them.
Then you'll be certain not to die in bed.